hi there are you as passionate about
programming as we are
if yes you are going to love our list of
the five top movies that capture this
high-tech exhilarating world stunningly
taking us vividly through the
significance of programming to the sheer
wonder of ai these hollywood
representations are a real must watch
for every programmer or budding
enthusiast
so let's dive right in happy watching
the first on our list is the pirates of
silicon valley a must for all
programming enthusiasts and also an
inspiration for startups and
entrepreneurs around the world it was
directed by martin burke and released in
1999.
the film depicts several events that led
to the i.t and computer revolution watch
how giants like microsoft and apple
designed personal computers get an
insight into other key industry players
ibm and xerox what's particularly
interesting is the depicted computing
wars between apple and microsoft right
from their beginnings the competition at
the time and the success of each
the main plot revolves around how steve
jobs the founder of apple and bill gates
the founder of microsoft ideated
brilliantly the creation of a personal
computer that everyone could benefit
from and how after a long tussle the two
firms finally announced their alliance
in 1997 to build a better world for
technology
thus if you're keen to learn how
personal computers were first developed
this movie is something you'll
absolutely love
next up we have antitrust which was
released in 2001 it is a techno thriller
film did you know that the world of
software also has its own dirty side
dive right into unravel as this is quite
an interesting take on the world you're
enthusiastic about the plot starts with
the ideal setup programmers working in a
corporation that not just pays well but
also offers a good working environment
a young talent a passionate programmer
gets the job in this organization only
to find out later of the wrong doings
that were being committed
this is where things start getting
attention grabbing the programmer goes
on to use his unique tech skills and
gets right to the bottom of it all
this movie is really an all-time
favorite for programmers globally as it
depicts the best ways of applying one's
sophisticated know-how in this domain it
hence still remains one of the best
programming movies of all time number
three on our list is jobs which was
released in 2013. it is a biographical
drama the film is based on the life of
steve jobs right from his school life
until the invention of the ipod the
movie of course depicts the success
story of jobs but it touches on some of
the more tangible inspiring elements
highlighting the way he worked the
creativity he put in and the game
changing mission that he had which
eventually changed the world the plot
revolves around creating and building
the apple company and the brand the
introduction of the iconic iphone which
went on to become the highest selling
product in the century the recreation of
the ipod launch scene that will
definitely leave you with goosebumps
ashton kutcher's portrayal of steve jobs
that was just phenomenal all in all the
story behind how apple became the
business enterprise it is today yes jobs
is one of the most motivating films for
people who have real ambitions and
dreams and who want to create a world of
success for themselves second on the
list is the imitation game if you love
working with numbers or algorithms this
one is especially an absolute treat for
you in fact all programmers may find the
film extremely engaging it came out in
2014 and revolves around the invention
of the world's very first computer by
alan turing and his team the imitation
game is historical drama based on the
life of the genius british mathematician
alan shuring who played an essential
role as a crypto analyst in deciphering
the enigma machine an encryption device
used by the nazis during the world war
ii to transmit code messages the sheer
fact that he imagined a computing
machine when people had no idea about
anything even close to it is absolutely
incredible he solved a problem that the
most talented and revealed could never
have in this way and the movie captures
the excitement of it all what's more
historians actually estimate that
breaking enigma shortened the war by two
plus years
saving over 14 million lives turing's
work inspired generations of research
into what scientists call sharing
machines today we call them computers
the topmost however on the list is the
social network the movie was released in
2010 it is a biographical drama and has
won the oscars for best adapted
screenplay best film editing and best
original score the film captures the
lives of mark zuckerberg and his friend
eduardo saverin showcasing them in
harvard university and the story behind
the most successful social media
platform ever seen facebook the movie
depicts that in 2003 harvard computer
sciences sophomore mark zuckerberg
launched a website called face smash
that would determine the attractiveness
of female students against one another
the site became an overnight sensation
among harvard students but stirred
controversies due to violations of the
harvard computer and privacy policies
subsequently it had to be brought down
despite its popularity this spurred
another innovation from zuckerberg and
his close friend sabrin and outlaunched
the facebook in early 2004 which as we
all now know went on to become the
world's biggest social networking site
facebook thus the plot takes you through
how facebook grew as a business giving
us interesting glimpses into the various
ups and downs along its way what's
unique is that even in a movie such as
this you would find yourself connecting
to what each of the characters feel as
their emotions have been depicted in the
most real-life manner there is no real
villain it's about the things that real
people do in real life to achieve
success like how one may commit
something immoral or screw over their
friends to get ahead of themselves
this film also makes you remember where
and why you started also confirming the
sheet heights a dedicated programmer can
really go on to achieve once capitalized
on their potential we hope you've
enjoyed this video the list doesn't end
here there are many other programming
movies that we think are good choices to
satisfy the programmer in you therefore
do let us know which movie you think we
have missed on our list and your
personal favorite on our list as well
all these programming movies are fun to
watch but at the same time our
information is well thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here